André Richard pour le groupe Union pour
un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Manuel
Valls ministre de l'Intérieur
ce ministre il y a quelques jours à
peine dans le cadre des questions
cribles sur le terrorisme je vous
interroge sur les mesures à prendre pour
tenter de contrôler les flux internet et
les réseaux sociaux
à Strasbourg en nous venons d'être
rattrapé par cette dangereuse réalité
les lycées sont en effet l'objet d'une
menace proférée depuis un cybercafé de
la cité le soir du 14 mai dernier un
internaute anonyme bien entendu a publié
un long message intitulé tout s'arrête
bientôt sur le forum d'un site web dans
lequel il annonce son intention ni plus
ni moins que de commettre un massacre
dans un établissement scolaire à l'aide
du semi automatique de son oncle je cite
si le dispositif de sécurisation des
établissements scolaires concernés cette
heureusement mise en place rapidement je
voudrais à cet égard en remercier
notamment Monsieur le Préfet de
département Monsieur le Procureur de la
République et les forces de police et de
gendarmerie concernées
il est clair que la menace ne doit pas
être considérée comme évacuer et que
plusieurs questions se posent à cet
égard
en premier lieu même s'il ne faut
surtout pas surenchérir dans de tels
circonstances il est indispensable de
rassurer la population alsacienne et
tout particulièrement les parents et les
élèves des établissements scolaires
concernés quant à une sortie prochaine
de cette situation de crise
à ce jour deux pistes ont d'ores et déjà
été exploités par les enquêteurs mais
les personnes interpellées ont été mises
hors de cause
sans mettre en difficulté la nécessaire
confidentialité de l'enquête pouvez-vous
nous donner monsieur le ministre
quelques informations à cet égards
ensuite plus de 500 policiers et
gendarmes sont mobilisés au quotidien
pour sécuriser les quelques 50
établissements de Strasbourg menacés je
ne parle même pas du Bas-Rhin ce sont
bien entendu autant d'effectifs qui
manquent sur d'autres champs auxquels
s'efforce sont normalement affectés
comment ces absences sont-elles
compensées
enfin les cybercafé comme les cartes
téléphoniques prépayées constituent une
zone de Total liberté de non-droits qui
permet dès lors tous les abus dont
celui-ci n'a-t-il pas lieu monsieur le
ministre de renforcer les outils de
veille électronique notamment dans ces
cybercafé voir d'instaurer une
obligation d'identification des usagers
de ces lieux et outils et pour être
encore plus efficace dans le contrôle
des flux internet ne faut-il pas doter
nos services de police judiciaire et de
renseignements des moyens humains
supplémentaires particulièrement formés
et aguerris
des nouveaux moyens de communication
quels sont monsieur le ministre les
questions que m'inspirent cet événement
survenu dans mon département et auquel
je vous remercie de bien vouloir la
parole est à Monsieur Manuel Valls le
ministre de l'Intérieur
sur le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Richard nous reprenons en effet une
discussion que nous avons eu et à
l'occasion de la loi anti-terroriste et
encore vous venez de l'évoquer jeudi
dernier lors des questions crimes sur le
terrorisme d'une manière générale nous
devons être
mobilisés parce que la menace est là en
France en Europe et dans le monde et les
derniers événements de ces dernières
heures en font la démonstration et après
le président de la République est le
premier ministre je veux
assurer la solidarité du gouvernement à
l'égard de nos amis britanniques qui ont
subi cette attaque particulièrement
terrible horrifiante qui pose beaucoup
de questions sur la nature de la menace
que nous connaissons la nécessité d'une
très grande mobilisation je veux à mon
tour monsieur le sénateur saluait le
travail l'engagement des de l'ordre dans
l'affaire que vous évoquez la menace
postée sur un forum de jeu a été repéré
rapidement et un dispositif adapté de
sécurisation de des lycées étaient mis
en place immédiatement il sera maintenu
le temps qu'il faudra ce sont 455 450
policiers et gendarmes qui assurent
aujourd'hui la protection de ces
établissements l'enquête se poursuit et
toutes les pistes sont exploitées là
encore l'engagement de la police
nationale et totale et la coordination
je crois est de bonne qualité trois
services sont engagés la sûreté
départementale chargée de
l'investigation de proximité la police
judiciaire bien sûr et enfin l'Office
Central chargé de la lutte contre la
délinquance liée aux nouvelles
technologies la détection de la menace
et la lutte contre les rumeurs qui se
répandent sur Internet passe enfin par
un travail accru avec des opérateurs et
les réseaux sociaux c'est par exemple ce
que nous avons entrepris avec Twitter
suite et le recrudescence ces derniers
mois de propos
antisémite et homophobe en matière de
surveillance Internet où nous avons eu
ce débat nous devons concilier les
impératifs de sécurité et les grandes
libertés constitutionnelles c'est une
tâche difficile mais les services ne
manquent pas d'outils techniques ou de
personnels spécialisés qui savent
identifier les cyberres délinquants ça
sera le cas évidemment pour la Direction
centrale du enseignement intérieur et
qui aura des moyens supplémentaires
notamment en matière de recrutement
toutes les technologies doivent être
exploitées dans le cas de Strasbourg
nous ne pouvons par exemple nous appuyer
sur les images de la vie de surveillance
du cybercafé en tout cas monsieur le
sénateur les menaces de Strasbourg
doivent être prises au sérieux le roteur
doit être identifié et qu'il s'agisse ou
non d'un canular il doit être sanctionné
c'est ce que nous faisons nous appelons
évidemment à cet objectif sans céder à
la panique mais avec beaucoup de
détermination merci